two figures any two in an oprah
interview where we get to the bottom of
all sorts of things chris you got a
trivia question for me to determine pick
number one okay here we go what kicker
is one of just five british-born players
to win a super bowl
hint he was born in scotland and he's
the only kicker in nfl history to make
two game-winning
overtime field goals in the playoffs
well he can't is it adam vina terry
i know i would that would have been my
guess too but he's not born in scotland
so that was not your yes i don't know i
don't know some trick like his dad was
in the service or something yeah some
fact i didn't know about well uh it's
lawrence tines which i i did not know
about the
i did not know that about him and it's
from he's from greenwich scotland it
doesn't spell like greenwich it's a very
scary saying actually as you look at it
fast hello greenwich let's just stick
with green go ahead take your first pick
well this is the best pick ever
i'm so glad i got the first one
i mean jack easter being anybody okay
but let's go jack easter bee and cal
mcnair just for fun let's flush it out
would you rather have jack easter be in
deshawn watson which one's uh i want
jack these to be into shawn walsh okay
fine let's go with that jack easter bee
and deshawn watson oprah in the middle
hitting them with the hard questions
come on that is like an interview made
in heaven i i'm tuning in to that hell
or yeah or hell i don't know i don't
really give a damn about you know the
the whole harry and i i know i've seen
some of the headlines whatever um i'm
not totally into that scene there but
damn i'd love to see oprah do these two
you probably get just as many good
quotes and drama out of that one
well
because i think desean would respond and
talk and open up in that setting and
jack easterby wouldn't know what the
hell to say pete carroll and russell
wilson my first pick
without question especially now right uh
with when when oprah holds up the season
ticket holder letter that doesn't
mention russell's name that's part of it
as well so that one's an easy and
russell what else and russell what were
you um what were you saying about the
offensive line and saks pete would you
care to comment
oh oh wait what what pete what happened
in that meeting when he stormed out can
you guys go into detail with that oh
that would be great that i know i was
torn between that one and and easter bee
but i had to go with easter b well after
that
i want to i want brady belichick you
know you know brady belichick
i i i want it all too i mean i'd like to
know the good things and all of that but
of course you know the rocky road times
as well and that's where oprah can get
you i mean she's just special that way
how she asks questions you know and
really can go into all the issues the
patriots had the contract issues what
happened at the end tom why did you feel
like you were disrespected by this man
and all that uh that one was was pretty
easy one of my first choices
this one would have to be done fairly
soon
but i want sean payton into a breeze
because that i want some answers and the
only way we're going to get answers is
get the two of them in a room and have
oprah there to draw the answers out of
them because drew still hasn't retired
we still don't know what the hell is
going to happen with the quarterback
position in new orleans now we may know
sooner rather than later but at least
for right now if they were doing it
today live drew and sean and oprah yeah
that that's that's a good one that was
on my list as well i mean i i am well
what what is going on there
what is drew brees exactly doing and
when is he going to make a comment on
this situation uh it's something that's
kind of flying under the radar right now
all right i feel like there's one i'm
missing somewhere
i really do uh but i think you know like
i would have i would have had jack and
jerry going into this if they just
didn't get done but i think the next one
i'm gonna go to right now
shanahan and garoppolo how could i not
pick that right now i mean we just all
the rumors out there about the 49ers
garoppolo he's great and that he never
makes comments or does anything like
that like i wasn't sure if i should go
shanahan garoppolo or garoppolo and
brady and maybe they could talk it out
while brady wanted to take his job last
year but i'll go with shanahan garoppolo
because of course is more relevant and
recent right now but yeah jimmy g's got
to be wondering where the hell do i
stand on this football team right now
and
nobody knows what really kyle shanahan
thinks in the situation they're saying
all the right things about jimmy
garoppolo but of course the signals
don't exactly tell us uh the right
things either
you mentioned jerry jones and look just
for sheer entertainment value you gotta
have one with jerry jones and it's been
a few years but jerry jones and roger
goodell they had quite
quite a battle a few years ago right and
my guess is that things aren't
completely fine between the two
individuals right now you know who's the
who's the the the alpha in that setting
and uh what would jerry say how would
roger respond to him i think that would
be fascinating i also had sean mcveigh
and jared goff yeah even though the
trade's going to happen there's
definitely some tension there that needs
to be explored definitely that was uh
the last name i had on there you know
what's a shame is it just it's all
quarterbacks and stuff like that like is
there any drama going on with any of the
position players no wonder position
players are sick of quarterbacks i mean
you just see it's just it's one story
after another quarterback quarterback
quarterback but you got anything else
out there yeah yeah a mike tomlin
antonio brown reunion would be
interesting yeah right you're right john
gruden and antonio
really antonio brown and anyone we could
get about the whole league to line up
with antonio brown we could probably
have a good interview
antonio brown and tom brady would
actually be fascinating because i'd want
to see how brown behaves around brady
and get a better insight onto how it is
and what it is that brady was able to do
right to finally get
antonio brown pointed in the right
direction and speak consistently to his
better angels and get him to stop the
self-destructive stuff that was
unfolding from 2019 into 2021 because
for brady it worked he got super bowl
ring number seven
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports